على مدار 20 عامًا ، كان مخيم جنين
للاجئين مرتعًا
للمقاومة العنيفة ضد الإسرائيليين
، كما كان أيضًا موقعًا
للتخطيط للهجمات ضد المدنيين
داخل إسرائيل نفسها ،
ولكن الآن هناك تغيير تدريجي في
الجو هنا وكأن شيئًا
أكثر من ذلك بكثير  عنيف هو أن يأتي
حدثًا لمعرفة السبب في
لقاء سري مع المسلحين الذين
هم على رأس قائمة المطلوبين في إسرائيل ،
نلتقي في ضريح للفلسطينيين
الذين قُتلوا وهم يقاتلون إسرائيل من
أجل الإسرائيليين ، وهذا يخلد ذكرى مقتل
هؤلاء الرجال  مطاردة
يقولون لأنهم مسلحون وهم
يخططون لشن هجمات ضد إسرائيل
قتل أربعة مسلحين وطفل يبلغ من العمر 12
عامًا في هذه الغارة في نهاية
سبتمبر.
هذا الرجل يقول إنه نجا من غارة إسرائيلية
على جانين قبل حوالي أسبوع
من رفيقه  قُتل
[موسيقى]
مثله هؤلاء أعضاء في لواء جنين ،
وهي جماعة مسلحة تشكل الآن خطرًا على
السلطة الفلسطينية وكذلك على
إسرائيل
لم يسمع بها من قبل  تنحنح لكسر الغطاء
للمقابلة ، ناهيك عن الاعتراف من أين حصلوا
على أسلحتهم قبل 20 عامًا ، كان لديهم
AK-47s الآن لديهم M16s حتى هذا
واحد كتب عليه باللغة العبرية ، لذا فقد تمت
سرقته من الإسرائيليين ،
أوه ، ليس جيدًا
نيس الأجنبي
وجد المجلس التشريعي أن هناك حوالي 400000
سلاح غير قانوني في إسرائيل ، تم
سرقة العديد منها من جيش الدفاع
الإسرائيلي ، فما هي بالضبط قواعد الاشتباك الخاصة بك ،
ما هي
القرارات الأخلاقية التي تتخذها بشأن
من تفعل ومن لا
تهاجمني؟
لست متأكدًا
[موسيقى]
كان هذا العام الأكثر دموية بالنسبة
للفلسطينيين والإسرائيليين منذ عام 2015.
قُتل ما لا يقل عن 123 فلسطينيًا خارج
غزة و 21 إسرائيليًا وأجنبيًا
مسلحًا من جنين والمناطق المجاورة لها
تورطوا في ما لا يقل عن
فظائعين كبيرتين قتل فيهما ثمانية أشخاص
قتلى في منطقة قريبة من تل أبيب في وقت سابق من
هذا العام عن
توسيع المستوطنات الإسرائيلية اليهودية
في الضفة الغربية وتضاؤل ​​الإيمان
بأن دولة فلسطينية قابلة للحياة يمكن أن
تنشأ من الاحتلال الإسرائيلي الذي دام 55 عامًا
أثار احتلال المنطقة المزيد من الغضب الفلسطيني ،
نعم المنظمات الشعبية مثل
لواء جنين هذا
تعارض بشدة وجود إسرائيل وتحتقر
السلطة الفلسطينية الحاكمة
لتعاونها مع الدولة اليهودية ،
فهذا يعني أن هذه
معركة ميؤوس منها تمامًا "  إعادة القتال
لأن الإسرائيليين لا أعتقد أنه
يمكنك هزيمتهم
ولن يذهبوا إلى أي
مكان ولديهم المجتمع الدولي
يدعمهم وفي
نفس الوقت هناك دعم
لفكرة حل الدولتين
الفلسطينيون من أجل
دولة فلسطينية مستقلة يشبه هذا نوعًا
من قبضة الموت التي أنت فيها الآن
، والماس هو ماسة
قوات الأمن التابعة للسلطة الأجنبية التي من المفترض
أن توقف الهجمات على إسرائيل
في حريق جديد ، ستكون
القيادة الفلسطينية هي التي يمكن أن تكون
الأولى  ليحرق